Hi everyone, well,
it's my real pleasure to
introduce Sabrina Rashid.
She is a PhD candidate at
Carnegie Mellon University
working with Sid Fargosid.
And she spent the summer looking
at applying deep learning to
single cell data, in particular
using, as she'll say,
using new variational
autoencoders to try to
understand the heterogeneity of
tumors from single cell data.
And I look forward to
hearing what she has to say.
Thank you.
[LAUGH] Hi, everyone.
As Rohu mentioned, I'm Sabrina,
a finishing cardio PhD student
at Carnegie Mellon University
Computational Biology
Department.
So in this summer
intern project,
we looked into single
cell tumor data.
And we know tumor comes from
very heterogeneous landscape, so
we wanted to find what are the,
can we identify
the underlying heterogeneity
from that single cell data.
So this is a brief
outline of the talk,
motivation, method, and
then results and discussion.
So let's first motivation.
As I mentioned,
intra-tumor heterogeneity
is one of the challenging
things when you want to decipher
tumor evolution for a subject.
So what happens is
that malignant cells,
even if they're coming
from a single tumor,
they'll have a very
distinct genomic profile.
So in terms of the gene
expression values or copy number
profile or mutations, each cell
will have something different.
So earlier,
when people use sequencing,
they used to do bulk sequencing
where you actually pull a bunch
of cells together and tjem
sequence all the cells together,
not at a individual level.
So what happens is that when you
do bulk sequence of such tumors,
it actually averages out
their genomic profile so
you lose their
heterogenic information.
So next came single cell
sequencing, which is
very important if you want to
unmask what are the underlying
heterogeneity or difference of
this different malignant cells.
But then single cell data
comes with its own sets of
computational challenges.
Since we are sequencing
at single cell, so
the quantity that you will
sequence is very little, so
the data is actually
very noisy and sparse.
By sparse, I mean there will be
a lot of genes that are in low
quantity, so it will not
be detected in many cells.
So hence, even though it's
expressed in a low level,
it will be a completely
zero in many cells,
so there will be drop out and
sparse.
So it becomes very hard to
extract biologically meaningful
features.
So that is the expression data.
Then again comes
the copy number and
mutation data from
DNA sequencing.
So to have high fidelity
estimation of mutation and
copy number profiles at
a single cell level,
you need very high
depth sequencing.
So, which is not
always possible.
Even if it's possible you'll
only be able to sequence only
a couple cells, not a large
cohort to analyze the data.
So here, we're using a
variational autoencoder to learn
a latent representation
of the single cell data
that is coherent with
the underlying biology, and
also generalized enough to the
different types of genomic data.
Different types I mean
Arnesic expression data and
also copy number data
from DNA sequencing.
So we know autoencoders are
these multilayered perceptron
neural networks that learn their
own definition of the data
in a completely
unsupervised manner.
But in variational autoencoder,
the concept of this unsupervised
deep learning is merged with
that of the Bayesian inference
where you actually, instead of
generating an unconstrained
representation of the data,
we assume that the latent
representation is actually
coming from a underlying
distribution.
If you think about it, it's like
how scientists observe nature.
You observe a nature phenomena
and you want to know what is
the underlying law that
is governing them, so
it's kind of like that.
Instead of learning
a unconstrained representation,
we want to learn actually
the distribution that
the latent representation
is coming from.
So here, this is the structure
of the autoencoder.
So you have the first input
there is the number of genes.
And then we have three
intermediate layers, and
then the last latent layer.
So how many nodes in each layer
and how many layers you wanted,
that can be user parameter for
the package.
So for the results that I will
show, I have used three latent
dimension in that
particular layers.
So here, instead of actually
encoding the latent
representation directly,
we are actually encoding for
the sample mean and sample
variance, and we're learning
the The distribution
given the input data.
Once we have that,
we can sample Z from that
learned probabilistic.
So it is kind of giving you
a probabilistic encoding of
the input data space.
And then there is
a complementary decoder network.
When we learn the structure, we
learn it as a whole encoding and
decoding, where we are learning
the parameters of the model.
But we are actually interested
in the latency presentation at
this, three-dimensional latency
presentation of the data.
So that is a brief overview of
the algorithm that we are using.
So we have actually had three
types of data sets that we
have tested our method.
One, our first gene expression
data says we have three
different single cell
RNA seq expression data.
The first one is with
over 4,000 cells,
second one's over 6,000 cells,
and the last one over 2,000, and
all of them has 23K genes.
Then we have copy number,
two copy number datasets
from DNA sequencing data.
These two are actually
xenograft samples, and
first sample has 260 and
the second sample is 254 cells.
These two xenograft samples are
sequenced at a very low depth,
so 0.05X.
And we can see that even with
this very low depth copy
number estimation,
we can still get some biological
meaningful output from the data.
And then last,
we wanted to quantify our
software proposed method with
some other existing techniques.
So that's why for
that we have used a synthetic
genetic expression data set
where we know actually how
many clusters are in there and
can compute some quantitative
metric to analyze the methods.
So first,
the oligodendroglioma data set,
where the data set content is
a mixture of malignant and
non-malignant cells.
We pass the data through
our autoencoder.
We can see there's a clear
separation between the malignant
and the non-malignant
microglia or macrophage cells.
Next, we wanted to see,
our goal was to unmask
tumor heterogeneity.
So we wanted to investigate
more the malignant cells.
So next, we passed the malignant
cells, the relative expression
of the malignant cells
only to the autoencoder.
And we get these nice
structures, so we are getting
a bifurcation-like structure,
a V-like structure.
Where you see that
cells are put on,
two different types of
cells are coming out, and
they're put on the two different
arms of the V structure.
So the first one, here,
the data that the paper
originally reported, they also
computed differentiation and
lineage metric for each of
the cells based on a set of
signature genes and
a set of control genes.
So to show that the two
different types of cells
are indeed put onto
two different arms,
we have actually colored our
scatter plot using their metric.
The first one is the lineage
score, which shows which cells
are oligo-like and
which cells are astro-like.
These are the two different
cell types that
are present in the data.
And we see a nice separation.
And then we also have the
differentiation metric, that is,
which cells are further
differentiated and
which cells are in
more stem-like.
So we do see, so looking at the
structure, we thought the most
stem-like cells should be near
the neck of the bifurcation.
And we do see that the more
stem-like cells are indeed put
in this side.
So also, this actually
shows how the autoencoder,
without using the prior
knowledge, we are actually
fishing out what are the
underlying tumor heterogeneity,
and how these two populations
are related to each other.
It's actually showing that even
though there are two different
cell types present,
they're actually coming
from the same lineage.
So this is with
the signature genes only.
Next, we wanted to see
whether we can find
same kind of structure without
using any signature in it.
Just automatically selecting
some cells based on maybe
coefficient of variation or
average expression level or
something.
So this is based on
average expression level,
with top 5,000 genes,
5,000 auto-selected genes.
And we can still see that it
gives a good separation of
the two different types
of cell population.
Next, we wanted to compare
with other methods,
whether they can capture
the same truth or not.
So the first one is the t-SNE.
t-SNE is really popular now
to do reduced dimension for
high dimensional data and has
been used in many single cell
processing and
RNA seq processing data sets.
But here, what t-SNE does,
it does show us separation.
But it's showing the separation
of different samples that
the tumors are coming from.
But it's not actually capturing
what is the state of each cell.
It's not showing any distinct
differentiation between the two
types of cells.
Then again, we have the PCA.
So PCA can show somewhat
separation, but
the structure is not as distinct
as we have for our autoencoder.
So next data set, that is,
next data set's the astrocytoma,
with over 6,000 cells.
Here again, we see clear
separation of the malignant in
figure a, malignant and
non-malignant cells.
And then again, we passed only
the malignant creative
expressions to the autoencoders.
And for this particular data
set, the authors didn't compute
the matrix that we had for
the earlier data set.
So to know what we
are getting at, I
plotted it on top of the matrix
from the previous data set.
So the solid dots actually from
the previous data sets and
marked with
the differentiation score.
And we do see that most of
the astrocytomas, the malignant
astrocytoma cells, are actually
falling in the stem-like region.
So when I went back to the
original paper to see whether it
makes sense or
not, we see that they do mention
that most of the cells in that
data set is actually in
the more intermediate states.
So it's actually capturing,
it's accurately capturing
their statement as well.
So this is another data set,
which is the leukemia data set.
And here we see
a separation of cell lines,
K562 cell line and
the other cells.
But we're not seeing a distinct
separation based on the BCR-ABL.
So these are gene mutation
status of each cell.
So we're not seeing a distinct
separation between these status,
but we do see a blunt
V-like structure.
Probably it is catching
something else that is common to
all these type of cells.
So this particular validation,
it actually needs more
biological analysis to see what
is, we see our trajectory, but
what are we actually
seeing biologically?
How relevant it is,
it needs further work.
I just wanted to show
the plot of this result.
So next,
we analyzed synthetic data sets.
So in the synthetic data set,
we have 500 cells,
3 to 4 each cell,
we have 3,000 genes, and
cells are coming from
5 different clusters.
So each cluster will
have 100 cells.
So for this particular one,
there is actually 2.5K cells
that are actually representative
of the cluster and
500 noisy cells.
When we pass it through
the autoencoder,
we see a very good separation
of the five clusters.
And when we estimate
the number of clusters using
a Gaussian mixture model,
we can see that the autoencoder
actually correctly predicts
there are five clusters,
which none of the other ones do.
t-SNE does capture three,
but the PCA is only one.
And also, we computed
the adjusted random index for
all of the cases.
And we see that we have
the maximum 0.98 for
our autoencoder compared
to the other two.
Next, we increased the number,
amount of noisy genes
to 2500 out of 3000.
So only 500 genes are actually
signal of the actual clusters.
And here,
the autoencoder is actually
picking up four clusters.
But still, with a much
better adjusted random index
score than compared
to the rest of ones.
So you can see PCA
is just a blob.
t-SNE, some separation
between two, but
not so much, so
their score is really low.
Then we also did
some comparisons.
So I showed you what autoencoder
structure we used in our paper.
And then we tried to see
whether we can, if we
remove some of the intermediate
layers, how does it affect?
It does get faster, but
it's not by much, it's 3.43.
And I'd say it's not that
expensive as runtime, but
we do get a better ARI compared
to the other structures.
And also, both of those
structures are faster than
t-SNE, and
t-SNE has slower metric.
Next star is all that I'm going
to show is the copy number, so
this is DNA sequencing data, so
the earlier ones were
RNA sequencing data.
So this is a DNA sequencing
data which I'm showing the two
samples on top are super
impulse on each other so
seen on both here xenograft
breast tumor samples.
You can consider xenograft
four as a later time point of
xenograft three.
What you can see here is
that in xenograft there,
there are two different clusters
that are one major clusters and
one minor cluster of the cells.
And when you progress,
after some treatment,
when you progress to the later
time point at xenograft four,
the minor cluster actually
vanishes, so from projecting in
that space you can clearly
see that which cluster.
So once we know that, we can
actually study those cells,
which properties make those
cells not progress into
the next time points,
but the major clusters.
And we can see also what is
the levels of this cluster.
You see this is
the copy number for
file of xenograft three samples
where you see that there is
a small cluster of cells that
has like twice the copy number
in this chromosome compared
to the rest of the cells.
So that is actually
what is captured
in the small cluster here.
So this group of cells
are actually not progressing to
the next time point.
So as I mentioned in the
beginning of the slide one of
the key problem of single
cell data is drop out so
it means like some of the genes
will not have any signal in many
of the cells.
So we wanted to see how robust
the auto encoder representation
is compared to
the drop out events.
So for
that we have used the same
three data with 2.5 genes
out of 3,000 genes.
And we can see that both PCA and
t-SNE after increasing
the number of dropouts
of couple of percentage.
They actually doesn't
capture more than one class.
So, they just capture
just one cluster so
that's why the ARI score has
dropped down to zero even after
increasing the percentage of
dropout more than 5% or so.
But encoder, it is degrading
the performance much,
but compared to the other two,
it's much better.
So upon to 10% we still
see close to 0.7, and
if we increase the number
of dropouts to 50%,
like half of the genes
are actually dropout.
And we see, I don't know,
like 0.3 or
0.4 so it's still
differentiating the clusters.
Maybe not as well as
the hierarchies but
its still showing,
it can identify the clusters and
can somewhat make
some differentiation.
So compared to the other
two it's much better.
So to summarize
what I have done,
we have proposed a new way of
extracting useful features with
biological significance
from single cell data.
Nice thing about is,
it's completely unsupervised and
it requires minimal
pre-processing of the data.
It's fairly robust to the
dropouts and we have the package
and that will be distributed
as an open source package.
In future, so
here all the result I have shown
as three latent dimension.
I started with three latent
dimension, just to visualize my
results and see and then I saw
that it's actually showing cited
and actually go beyond the three
dimension, later point.
But I would actually
interested to
investigate latent dimensions.
Cuz in the three that I
mentioned we actually can see
differentiation between
different cell types but
maybe if we go beyond that maybe
some other dimensions will
capture some other aspects
of the hydrogeny to suggest
[INAUDIBLE] environment or
how the cells will respond to
treatment response and
so on and so forth.
And also I showed you
some results that we're
seeing that kind of trajectory
or differentiation parts but it
definitely needs more research
on what is the biological
significance of that structure
that we're learning.
So, for the CML data, I still
have to do a lot more on that.
And so these are two immediate
main goals of the current
work that I want to do.
And so, some references.
Yeah, that's pretty much
my work that I have done
in the last 12 weeks,
yeah, okay.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Any questions? Yes.
>> Is single cell sequencing
still basic research or
is it being used in
translational applications?
Are people actually using
it in the clinic today or
is it really just
basic research?
>> Yeah, at this point,
it's just basic research.
I don't think there-
>> I haven't heard of any
clinical applications.
>> Yeah, I don't think there's
clinical stuff yet, yeah.
>> Gotcha, and are you gonna
publish a paper on this as well?
>> I think so, yeah,
we have actually finished
writing the draft.
>> Okay.
So, just polishing a bit and
then probably submit
it somewhere.
>> Awesome.
>> Yes?
>> Is it possible to interrogate
the transformation into
the latent space to learn about
the underlying biological model?
Or do you have to go
kinda the other way,
say here's some factor that
we know biologically, and
this is how it differentiates
in the latent space?
>> So, I don't know how we can,
so even our scale work,
just to get the underlying,
the structure level of
the autoencoder to learn?
>> Sure, I mean,
there's a lot of structure in
the trajectory or manifold,
however you wanna describe it,
in the latent space.
Is there a way to interrogate
that structure to learn
something about biology.
This is sort of to your
second future point work,
I'm curious what your
approach is gonna be.
>> Yes, so the immediate one,
I think that we're seeing this
trajectory or medical learning,
but we can see how the gene
expression levels are
progressing in that trajectory
and see is there any distinct
change in the expression
level we are seeing in that.
Maybe that can be a insight for
biology, and it can probably,
so we know about signature genes
that is particular to some
developmental process or
disease process or something.
So after learning
that trajectory,
that might also point us to new
genes that we didn't know that
is actually playing a role
in this particular process.
So after learning
that trajectory,
maybe we can find more about
those kind of genes that were
not previously experimented and
investigated.
So that is one immediate thing
that comes to my mind, but,
again, yeah.
>> I didn't fully
understand some part of it.
So if you have a deeper tree
as far as how the cells
are evolving and the finality
is kind of a bit deeper,
it seemed like there
were only really two.
What would be the depth
of the tree for
the data sets that
you used as far as?
>> Yeah, so the actually comes
out of autoencoder projection,
so we don't have any parameters
to control how deep up the tree
that really.
So some cases that, for example,
so for those expression letters,
for some of them,
we see a two branch thing.
But for some of them we don't.
Say, for example, here,
this malignant cells,
there is actually one line.
So it's not, maybe there is not
two distinct cell population.
It's just showing a trajectory
of one cells developing
trajectory or something, maybe
there is no differentiation.
For this particular
astrocytoma data sets here,
most of the cells are in one
particular plot, which is more
intermittent cuz it's not
differentiated well enough.
So it's the depth of the tree,
it's not that we
are controlling,
it's what the autoencoder
is learning on its own.
>> How would you change the
autoencoder structure to capture
a deeper tree, or, I mean, this
is presumably in the data, or?
>> Probably, yeah, so our
intuition is that autoencoder,
if it's working good, it should
be able to if there is any
deeper branching of the cells,
it should be able to capture it.
So that is our intuition.
We haven't tested any data
set that had a deeper, yeah,
deeper branching.
>> So you don't need more
latent variables or anything,
[INAUDIBLE]
>> Yeah, so there is also we
want to investigate more
latent variables later to see.
Our intuition is that different
latent dimensions may
capture a different aspect
of the cell property.
Maybe some cells are coming from
a different micro environment.
Maybe that is reflected
on that or not.
At least, my intuition
was something like that.
More latent dimensions might
capture more tumor cell
properties than we
are seeing here.
>> Do things like
cell cycle effects,
do those kind of average out or
they'd be an issue here?
So one way to account for
the cell cycle effects is if you
exclude the genes that are known
for being active for cell cycle.
We haven't excluded any genes
based on any prior knowledge, so
it's including everything here.
>> Well thank you, everybody,
thank you, Sabrina [INAUDIBLE]
>> [APPLAUSE]